[Music]
for some reason Eric is in love with
with Donnie he hugged you once and he
came in his pants or something yeah well
he first approached me at the urinal
down the hallway right and if you think
my wife and I get close is in the
serious building Eric walked right up
while I was peeing and handed me a
letter yes I went in and I read it and
he said he was a huge fan and wanted to
be on Blue Bloods little did I know he
was masturbating to blue blood and
Friday night Yeah right I felt like I
was touched I was touched I was touched
Jordan you don't know anything about
this I'd slightly have heard a little
rumor in place I didn't know you love
Donnie and right now yeah jerk ups he
jerks off to do your blue blood Steve no
no one opening is it that is it a dinner
scene that puts it over the top when I'm
asked not supremacy okay guys that would
be when do you climax when he's like
beating people up yeah when it yeah
Jason too bad guys yeah I wasn't even
sit at the desk and two dedicated people
that's when you're wrong nothing what
about when he's cussing people know
everything about it wasn't know what
those guys all right but he's in those
scene now and yes here's the thing and
he I will say I don't know what he does
while I'm interrogating cuz you sitting
out a desk he may actually be
masturbating on the stage you know Marty
you'll get a restraining order from
their stalker
Donny embraces Eric and you've said that
people come up to you now all the time
and constantly ask you about Eric I've
had I've had six career incarnations in
my life so when I was younger I'd be
like hey you were new kids my sister
loved you and then it was hey I didn't
know that was you in the sixth sense and
hey I loved you in bandar brothers now
it's hey blue bloods in for the last
year and a half
hey where's high-pitched seen high pitch
late I mean every in our concerts now
the wives they bring their husbands yes
so you know every five or six people
that we meet before a show is a husband
right every single one of them is like
where's high pitch so high you are
really linked to Donnie now I mean you
really are you create
congratulations Jordan you knew none of
us I know what this is a total Drive
like rumors like little rumors about
although I didn't know it was like legit
I thought it was just Donny was just
saying you know crazy story no they sat
there and said he actually he jerks off
you noticed even if there was something
going and do it a little buzz about cat
going up my singing voice actually
tightened up better I get when he walked
in I didn't notice my vocals kind of
kept up a little bit Jordan almost ran
out of the room was like a monsters